we knew that avengers endgame was
setting the path for the Young Avengers
to appear in the MCU at some point in
the near future
and now it has been reported that the
Young Avengers are in fact coming to the
MCU in their very own Disney Plus show
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
this is really big and a really exciting
news
The Young Avengers coming to the MCU
opens up the future of this Marvel
Cinematic Universe to so many great
characters if you take a look back at
everything that has happened in the past
Avengers in game and everything that is
coming to phase 4 the movies and the
Disney Plus shows it's the perfect time
to introduce the young Avengers so let's
break down this report that says the
young Avengers are getting their own
Disney Plus series but first don't
forget to subscribe hit the like button
and comment down below with your
favorite superhero or villain so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 I'm picking a winner
at 500,000 subscribers also you can
follow me on twitter and click the link
in the description down below for your
chance to win a Nintendo switch so the
Young Avengers making an appearance in
the MCU have been rumored for quite some
time now and Avengers in game definitely
set up some members of the Young
Avengers to appear in the future as well
but now the rumors can be put to rest as
Daniel Richmond and industry insider has
confirmed that Marvel and Disney are
officially working on a new Avengers now
he does say that there is potential and
there could be a young Avengers movie
however he does say that Disney and
Marvel really want to do a limited
series run for the team now I know a lot
of people would like to see a young
Avengers movie but there is a lot of
good of doing a series first remember
just because Disney introduces some
characters during a Disney Plus series
does not mean that they cannot later go
on to have their own movie because
everything is connected to the MCU all
of Marvel's Disney Plus shows are in the
MCU and having the Young Avengers have
their own series first gives Marvel
enough time to slowly introduce them and
their stories they don't have to have a
movie that rushes all of the character
story arcs with their series on Disney
plus they can take time and introduce
the characters the proper way and the
characters are really what make the
Young Avengers just to list a few of the
young Avengers we have Hawkeye hoechlin
Marvel Boy speed Wiccan
iron lad kid Loki Patriot stature and of
course there are more but let's talk
about the ones that are already set up
to be in the Young Avengers in the MCU a
really big one obviously being iron lad
Harley keiner
we saw him there at the end of Avengers
in game at Tony Stark's funeral
we know that Tony was his idol and we
know at the end of Iron Man 3 Tony gave
him a lot of tech and he most likely
kept in touch with him and pepper most
likely stays in touch with him as well
and then we have ant man's daughter
stature in Avengers in game we saw that
she is now pretty grown up and we know
from ant-man and the wasp that she
definitely wants to be a superhero so
she's in line to be in the New Avengers
as well then we have Wiccan who is a
reincarnated version of Wanda the
scarlet witch's son and of course vision
is the father well we know that we're
getting a Wanda vision Disney Plus
series so it makes sense that Wiccan
would appear and then we have Hawkeye
but not Clinton Barton we have Kate
Bishop who we already know is going to
be in the Hawkeye series coming to
Disney Plus and she's a really big part
of the Young Avengers but Daniel Richman
also says that the champions could be a
part of the Young Avengers as well and
that means that Miss Marvel could be in
the Young Avengers Miss Marvel is
already getting a Disney Plus series of
her own so maybe after her series and
she can join the Young Avengers so the
team for the Young Avengers really has
some awesome characters and what's
really exciting about the MCU
introducing the Young Avengers is that
over the next 15 to 20 years we're going
to see their characters develop and play
out to eventually become the new
Avengers of course there's going to be
some grown up Avengers teams along the
line of the MCU but eventually the Young
Avengers will become the Avengers so
it's really exciting news but let me
know what you all think about this who
would you like to see in the Young
Avengers team and are you excited for it
be sure to let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below and again don't
forget to comment with your favorite
superhero or villain like this video and
subscribe to my channel for a chance to
win an Xbox one or a ps4 and again you
can click the link in the description
down below to enter a giveaway for your
chance to win a Nintendo switch don't
forget to follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof